and their will is woe to us
Indeed, we were in clear air.
We were clearly misguided.
Clearly, upon disbelief,
clearly wrong. and this
articulates a level of a level
of regret that they are saying
we were wrong
but regret, yes, regret is
repentance. The prophet said,
regret, contrition is
repentance. And repentance is
contrition. That's how it is
epitomized. And a person's
repentance will not be accepted
by Allah if they do not have
contrition and regret for what
they've done. They have to
acknowledge that what they've
done is wrong and that they
regret this, this occurred,
that this happened. did this.
However, the contrition is
correct. The statement is
correct. Indeed, we were
clearly upon wrong. We were
clearly misguided. However, the
timing is incorrect. Too little
too late as we say. because a
person who repents to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala when
Allah's punishment is upon
them, in the final thrashes of
death, everyone believes in
Allah at that point. Everyone
repents to Allah unanimously.
The good and the bad and the
ugly, everyone of us is going
to leave this world with the
feeling, with the overwhelming
feeling of, indeed, I was upon
clear air. Everyone, everyone
of us is going to that feeling.
Some will have it more
intensely than others. But no
matter what we do, we're always
going to feel we could
have done better. So, a
believer and a disbeliever,
they have this. They have this
similar Similar emotion in
times of difficulty. The
difference between the believer
and the disbeliever is when
People usually fall asleep,
usually ignore Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
are ungrateful to Allah, the
believer, is constantly
vigilant of Allah is constantly
repenting to Allah. not because
they are in discomfort, they
are repenting to Allah because
he is owed repentance and he is
owed gratitude and he is owed
patience in time of hardship.
and so the believer repents to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
times of ease and in times of
hardship. However, every person
would repent to Allah in times
of hardship. Now, this is not
to say that a a believer's
death and a disbeliever's death
is the same. Of course, it is
radically different. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
that a disbeliever when they
are or or a person of
wickedness when they are swept
up by death, the angels of
punishment will come to collect
their souls. and the believer,
the angels of mercy will come
to collect their souls. The
experience of death is much
different. However, the
thrashes of death, the throws
of death are very difficult and
the fear and anxiety a person
will experience and their
retrospection into their past,
we will all have an
overwhelming feeling of of
regret for what we have, what
we have passed up.
has collected in his with an
acceptable chain of narration
that the prophet said
[Silence]
old age. On the day of
resurrection, he will look at
it with a level of
belittlement. Say, I could've
done better. I should have done
more. I should have done
better. That is due to the
terror of the day of
resurrection and due to thee,
overwhelming of what Allah is
really do that people are
asleep and when they die, they
wake up And they see reality
and see things for what they
truly are. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions that their call
of
Woe to us, indeed, we were upon
error will continue to be
there. Announcement until we
make them as a harvested burnt
out crop. This is to articulate
the the way that these towns,
these places are after Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Has
ravaged them with punishment.
Due to their misdeeds. But
Allah
The
[Silence]
between in any type of play or
just This is an important
statement here that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala does not
create anything in play or for
no good reason or ingest or
idly and we see this a lot. We
see this ascribed to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala by
idolaters throughout history
even in some of the Hindu text
mention in some of the Hindu
texts of Leela that the Gods
created the earth and humanity
for play, for sport, Likewise,
we find this in other pagan
cultures. Such as Greek
mythology, Roman mythology,
Persian mythology. Where the
gods are running around and
playing games and playing
sports. and it's all just a big
game and fun
that the gods are amused by the
suffering of mankind Likewise,
in other religions such as
Christianity and Judaism, there
are things ascribed to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala of this
nature. such as the notion that
as they say in America, things
god has a sense of humor,
right? When something
inexplicable happens or
something that seems ironic.
See, god has a sense of humor.
This is incorrect.
is a major misconception to
ascribe to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to have willed let alone
created anything without any
good reason, anything in idle,
ingest, for fun, just for
sport, just because you know,
it's fun. No. This is not the
description of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Furthermore, if
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
wanted to create anything for
sport, for fun, for amusement.
Would this be the creation that
was for amusement? Murder and
tragedy and pain and suffering,
and hunger, and poverty, and
illness, and disease, and war,
and would this be the
amusement? What kind of
sadistic amusement would that
be? Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
refutes this. He says, and we
have not created the heavens
and the earth and all that is
in between, in play, in sport.
but had we desired sport, such
sport if we had desired any
amusement, we would have taken
that amusement from that which
is closest to us. Amusement of
that which is in paradise, that
which is good, that which is
pleasureful pain and suffering
and disease and illness and
insanity and how can these
things be taken as some kind of
sport, some kind of fun, some
kind of sick joke.
Now Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
refutes that anything was
created for play and if it were
to have been created for play,
it would not have been in this
way. He says, Subhanahu wa
ta'ala expressing the purpose
behind this world and all that
it contains and everything that
he has created. Because a
person may say, Yeah, okay. He
doesn't create anything ingest,
anything in play, anything for
sport, for amusement then what
is with all of these tragedies
around us? What is with all
this pain and suffering that's
in the earth? What is with
thee? The great, the great
realities of of life, illness,
or death, or or old age. What
is with all of this? Why would
Allah create this? The Greeks
in their mythology the Hindus
and their mythology, the Romans
as well. They couldn't believe
that. A good god would create
all of this. So, they came up
with this idea that there were
many gods and they were
constantly fighting with each
other which Allah will address
in a few verses. That they are
constantly fighting with each
other and this is the tragedies
that place on this Earth
because this is kind of the
battleground for the gods. and
so they come up with all these,
you know, the Titans and the
Olympians and they're fighting
and clashing and all kinds of
very bizarre stories that come
out of this. Trying to make
sense of volcanoes and
earthquakes and tornadoes and
lightning and right? So, they
come up with all these things.
And so, if this is their
belief, they must come to the
conclusion that, well, this is
all for fun, for amusement.
That's why all of this pain and
suffering has been, has been
created, and this is why we
find a thread of sadism
throughout, throughout these
mythologies. We see the gods
that they depict are gloating.
in the suffering of men. They
enjoy it. So, you have for
instance, Aries and Hera and
these these, you know, these
gods, they punish the people on
the earth and then Hercules
comes along and this one comes
along and he saves the day
because he's always protecting
humanity from from, the evil of
these sadists.
very twisted and if a person
were to take these beliefs to
heart, they would be a very
terrible person Rather Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says, we
have not created anything in
the heavens and the earth.
for the purpose of amusement or
sport and had he desired to
create something for amusement
or sport it would not be this
here. It would not be in this
form. Allah then tells us the
reason why he subhanahu wa
ta'ala truly created this world
in the way that it is with all
that it has in it of good and
bad, pleasure, and pain. He
says, rather, Everything from
the heavens to the earth to all
that is in between has been
created in order that the truth
may overcome evil
in order that the truth may
overcome evil. In order that
those who worship him, worship
him in this environment, an
environment of choice. and that
the justice of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is imposed, and
likewise the mercy of Allah is
graced upon his creation.
[Arabic recitation]